ladies and gentlemen there's a story
that i haven't been able to talk about
for a long time the story of the person
jay mazzini kidnapped but today i'm
breaking my silence on this because the
kidnapping victim of jay mazzini just
got arrested for taking a bribe from jay
mazzini to change his story and you
better believe i have a lot to say about
it let's get into it ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host
coffee time
and as some of you original zillow
holders know pump the stock one of our
first investigations that really blew up
was the jay mazzini story we first
covered him doing giveaway scams that
eventually moved to bitcoin it
eventually resulted in criminal charges
being pressed against jay mazzini it's
quite the insane story and while the
walls were closing in he actually
kidnapped somebody that he thought ran a
scam page that was exposing him at the
time he thought he would kidnap this
person and it seemed like he was going
to try to get that person to remove or
delete the scam page that story went
everywhere we everyone knows he got
arrested for that later he got charged
with the bitcoin stuff but initially he
was picked up for that kidnapping charge
and so he got charged with that okay
that victim
goes on instagram by the name of mj
moves i would not suggest going and
following him because i don't
i get the weird feeling now
given what i know now that there's this
weird clout element to things obviously
not to say that any anything that
happened to him is as a result of clout
but um judging from the situation after
talking to him uh and after everything
that's happened now i get this weird
feeling like after everything happened
he kind of had this angle
to him like or where he was trying to
get something out of this terrible
situation which happened to him and it
makes me uneasy about the whole thing
because as some of you know i talked to
him right after the incident he was
still like
wounded i mean i'll throw up a picture
of him after right after the kidnapping
i mean he had been beaten he had been
stripped naked there was a machete held
to his neck i mean it was a crazy story
that has been reported on a lot and we
talked about it during that show
afterwards he came to me he said hey
steven
don't show this
thing because of the fact that hey i'm
working with detectives i don't know if
they're ready to have the story up i say
fair enough but i'm not trying to you
know hurt your case now during that time
jay mazzini's locked up
and i guess it's coming out now
that the family of j mazzini then
approached mj moves um the guy who was
kidnapped with kind of a
what seems like a bribery deal okay
about his statement to the feds this is
the the headline man allegedly kidnapped
by jay mazzini charged with taking bribe
to recant statement and apparently uh
our boy mj accepted this thing and uh
got what
allegedly in a hundred thousand dollar
payment in return for a new statement
that was meant to facilitate the release
of one of the defendants from jail aka
jay mazzini now to be clear it's a
little confusing because i guess if he
had gotten cleared from that charge
they're basically paying him a hundred
thousand dollars to get jay off but even
if that had happened i think he still
would have been in prison for the
bitcoin stuff it's not clear but yeah
they were trying to get him off of the
kidnapping charge with by by basically
paying the guy off with a bunch of money
now around the time this stuff happened
i'll just give you guys kind of full
transparency here i had heard rumors
that this may have happened and i did
call mj moves about it i picked up the
phone i won't be too specific here
because even though i think what he's
done is terrible here for the victims of
jay mazzini i still want to respect his
privacy to some extent as much as i can
but essentially the conversation was
you're not thinking of taking a bribe
are you and he's like well i can't tell
you that basically i'm like don't do it
that's idiotic i just because i had all
i had heard was rumors i didn't know
what was true what was not i just heard
rumors from um some of the various
people covering this i said this is a
terrible idea do not do that it's going
to hurt the victims who have been
affected by jay mazzini and now it looks
like he
allegedly took it okay and of course it
looks like i was right that it was of
course a bad idea to take a bribe you
know because uh he was arrested for this
and charged with accepting a bribe i
believe he's out right now on release
but i think that he's um i think that
he's just waiting to be uh like go to
court for this and this ladies and
gentlemen is sort of what i meant by um
i felt like well i feel now i guess i
didn't know then that he had his own
angle because it seems like he was
trying to use the situation not at first
but at first it seemed like he was just
like trying to get justice and then he
later used the information for his own
benefit uh now at this point that's kind
of my
involvement in this whole thing i know
many of you guys wanted to cover this
because you go what the heck you know
the guy who was kidnapped was you know
now charged and stuff but i also want to
cover the instagram stories he's been
putting out there because he's been
talking about it uh publicly a little
bit now initially when he got kidnapped
i think he released a story that said
like the plot thickens which weird thing
to say when you've been arrested but uh
then he's kind of goes on social media
uh later on and he's still cavalier
about it in a story they say are you
doing well i'm doing just fine he's
doing an ama about his um kidnapping
charge here he's answering you know why
did you change the j mazzini story let's
see what he has to say i added
more to the story and they're claiming
that i'm lying but all i ever did was
reveal more truths okay so he's saying i
didn't um change the story i just
accepted a hundred thousand dollars to
add more truths yeah um i'm gonna have
to say i don't really buy that too much
it's and it's so frustrating to see this
because again jay mazzini hurt a lot
more people than just this guy obviously
this guy probably the most but um yeah
this is not not helpful this one he's
talking about uh the family of jay
mazzini
contacting him since they've been trying
to harass me ever since trying to harass
my family anybody that can get close to
me they tried okay um here's another
question he was asked did jay snitch on
you i'm just gonna go through these
quick no why would jay snitch on me i
don't know maybe because he's willing to
kidnap you um to shut down the scam page
i mean it's absolutely crazy this is one
of the things i've got to say i mean
again i'm still i'm still planning to
not release the interview just yet
because i still don't want it to um you
know affect the situation negatively but
i remember even during the interview him
being like insanely naive
with regards to jay mazzini i mean it's
like it's crazy how much this guy even
after everything that's happened somehow
still like is kind of just has this
attitude of like oh yeah sure like i'll
do whatever it's actually completely
weird like i don't know how anybody
would have this attitude about somebody
who kidnapped them here's another one
saying why not 250k no comment but i
don't comment on you guys don't know
okay and i'm gonna keep it like that but
you little eighth grader
you would have been bought with a
thousand dollars so get the out of here
with your stupid
comments okay
this is annoying i i don't actually
think that's true i don't think everyone
would just take a bribe from somebody
who who kidnapped them that's extremely
weird especially if you know how many
people they've taken money from you know
where that money's coming from it's like
so frustrating to hear him say this
you've got to understand guys like in a
way i almost feel like that he's
betrayed all those people that i've also
talked to about james it's so
frustrating because it's like oh he was
a victim but then he's kind of using it
to his own devices so frustrating all
i'm gonna say is his wife is the reason
he's locked up and everyone else is off
up and she's the reason that we're going
through all this to begin with and she's
also the reason you guys all got scared
um
i don't really know what to think of
that one i do know quite a bit about the
story um some people have said that his
wife behind the scenes had stuff going
on
honestly you guys have seen how this
stuff has moved it is not some puppet
master pulling the strings okay yes his
wife got arrested after him but uh jay
mazzini he was doing his own thing too
this guy i think he's just trying to
blame it on the wife i don't know what
this guy's thinking and ladies and
gentlemen that was basically the last
relevant story he's posted about this
it's shocking given how much trouble
he's in how much he's talking about this
publicly uh but yeah he is and so of
course we're going to cover it i've got
to say i mean i can't express how
frustrated i am um on behalf of a lot of
the victims who are were are finally
seeing justice you know for what jay
mazzini has done and this guy's
basically undoing it or trying to undo
it for a hundred thousand dollars
extremely frustrating to see and um yeah
i'm i'm bothered by it for me personally
i can't release our interview in good
conscience right now because of all the
things that have come to light but
ladies and gentlemen that pretty much is
where we're at with this story we'll
have to see you know whether he ends up
going to facing any serious charges for
this it seems like he could uh but i
think that puts the lockup count on jay
mazzini as like three arrests now jay
mazzini jamizini's wife and now the guy
jay mazzini has kidnapped this has
become quite the story we will continue
following up on it so with that said
ladies and gentlemen thanks for watching
um i appreciate all of you and i will
see you guys
in the
fraud are next the same as choice